[Music]
just trying to rattle me I'm trying to
save you
what are you 23 Hey
[Music]
[Music]
when I some was like I was seeing a
ghost like every trigger I've ever
pulled
how'd he start you hunting birds rabbit
I guess in nineteen twenty years old the
first time he ordered you to shoot a
person
25 years ago he took my blood
made you from me
has been lying to you the whole time
told you you were an orphan and all the
people in the world to come after me why
would he send you
because I'm the best you are obviously
not the best and just trying to rattle
me trying to save you you made a choice
to do this to me
the whole point of this thing was to
give you all of Henry's gifts without
his pain I don't want to shoot you
mind if I shoot you and raise this ever
having you before your own government
trying to kill you that's new
everything that we've worked for is at
stake
[Music]
he has to die is your darkness you had
to walk through this on your own I love
you Junior
we created
or the inspiration for all of us why not
just make a whole army full of it why
not you should be flattered you should
be dead
this has to be stopped
because what if somebody actually know
what we really are
[Music]